[Music]
good morning
i want to begin by expressing my
gratitude to ontarians for remaining
attentive to public health advice
the last two years have been challenging
and i want to thank ontarians for their
ongoing resilience and commitment to
community as we navigate the global
pandemic together
your sacrifices and collective actions
will continue to make a difference as we
navigate what is now the seventh covid19
pandemic wave driven by ba5 omicron
subvariant
this variant has been increasing and
prevalent since early june and is now
the dominant strain in ontario
ba5 is more transmissible which is
reflected in the data we have seen in
the last few weeks
including an increase in the provincial
wastewater signal
as well as increases in the percent
positivity covert related
hospitalizations and icu admissions
while we've entered a new wave ontario
is experiencing a slower trajectory in
this wave
as compared to previous waves and we
expect to see the peak of this activity
in the next two weeks
our ability to keep this wave in check
is in large part to the high vaccination
rates and the availability of effective
treatments and therapeutics such as
paxlovid and every sheld
though this wave is expected to be less
severe there are actions we can continue
to take to minimize the impact on our
health system protect ourselves our
loved ones and our friends the most
important message which we've said
consistently is to stay up to date with
your covert vaccinations
millions of ontarians have not received
all their recommended vaccinations
5 million ontarians have yet to receive
their first booster and over 1.6 million
ontarians at the highest risk for severe
outcomes have not received their second
these individuals are strongly
encouraged to do so as soon as possible
to protect themselves from severe
illness and hospitalization especially
for those that are over 60 years of age
while my call for arms remains the
loudest for the most vulnerable in our
communities we've made the decision to
expand the eligibility for second
boosters to include ontarians aged from
18 to 59 years of age
beginning july 14th individuals in this
age group may choose to get a second
booster if it has been five months since
receiving the previous booster dose
and at least three months after any
covid 19 infection
while we're making this option available
it is important to note that healthy
currently vaccinated individuals
continue to have significant persistent
protection against severe disease even
six months after the last dose
however there may be individuals with
personal or medical circumstances in
those age groups who may benefit from an
additional protection of a second
booster
ontarians if they have questions may
speak to their health care provider
about whether getting a second booster
dose is right for them
additionally if you are at increased
risk for severe illness have a plan for
accessing pcr testing and treatment if
you develop symptoms
our community access centers remain open
the antiviral treatments ram desevir and
paxlovid are effective tools for helping
to protect ontarians to reduce
hospitalization and safeguard our
healthcare system
those with most severely compromised
immune systems also have access to every
sheld which provides safe effective and
long lasting protection in many
instances greater than six months
so if you're at high risk for severe
illness i encourage you to speak with
your health care provider to learn about
the treatment options and have a plan in
play
we want all ontarians to have a safe and
enjoyable summer and in addition to
staying up to date with vaccines and
knowing your treatment options there are
other actions everyone can take to keep
yourself in the community safe when
making plans for your summer take the
opportunity to gather with friends and
family outdoors it's also important to
stay home if you are sick even if you
have mild symptoms
practicing regular hand hygiene cough
etiquette and continue will help
continue to control the spread of this
virus and while masking requirements are
no longer mandatory in most settings
ontarians should consid continue to
consider wearing a mask in indoor
crowded spaces if they feel it's right
for them particularly if they're
spending time with older and more
vulnerable ontarians
for those who are at increased risk of
severe illness from covet 19
particularly those who have not received
all their doses appropriate doses of the
vaccine it is strongly recommended that
you continue to wear a mask in indoor
public spaces
in spaces where you may encounter people
who are especially vulnerable such as
hospitals and long-term care facilities
you should continue to expect to wear a
mask as the standard of care in those
settings
to further support
efforts to manage cover 19 we will be
continuing the broad distribution of
free rapid antigen tests in ontario
you will still find free tests in places
such as grocery stores pharmacies as
well as workplaces schools hospitals
retirement homes and long-term care
facilities
this will be continued and reassessed by
the end of the year
as i mentioned ontario now is in the
seventh wave but we have the tools to
manage it as the virus continues to
circulate and evolve we know what steps
need to be taken to protect ourselves
our communities and our health care
system the most important is to stay up
to date with your vaccinations i will
again thanks provide thanks to everyone
for continuing to follow public health
advice thank you and i can take
questions now can you tell us why you
waited until this point in the seventh
wave to open up the eligibility for
boosters moreover do you know how many
vaccine doses were thrown away while
pharmacists waited for this decision to
be made
so
as you've heard me uh over the last
several weeks we've been having a call
to arms for those that are the most
vulnerable so the five million ontarians
that haven't had their first dose and
the 1.6 million that haven't had their
second dose that's been our consistent
and persistent message we're now opening
up eligibility to those that have
between 18 and 59 years of age that have
evidence to support them getting a
second booster dose so that primarily
those who should consider getting that
vaccine or those with underlying medical
illness because they'll get the greatest
benefit so if you haven't had your
booster dose yet you're between 18 and
59 and you smoke or have diabetes and or
any underlying illness please consider
getting that booster dose this is timely
advice for the general public um we we
know it's the summer time and people
want uh to to move on past the pandemic
but it's a clear reality now that we
have to deal with this ba 5 variant
we need all ontarians to come forward to
get vaccinated as far as
wasted dosage
we
are meeting a standard of care
consistent across ontario
and can have those numbers to you in the
next couple of weeks am i going to get
the second booster dose in pharmacies
anywhere different and what about kids
are they eligible for a booster doctor
so right now it's 18 to 59 and thanks
for that question all our pharmacy
partners
public health units have been briefed as
well as those that provide vaccine in
their primary care clinics are
absolutely willing to provide the
vaccine our capacity at present is
roughly 100 000 ontarians a day that we
can vaccinate and and although we've had
a significant increase in the last
several weeks we're up to roughly 16 000
people immunized yesterday we have
capacity to immunize anyone interested
in maintaining the level of protection
we need uh to combat this nasty
aggressive virus
you have protection up to six months if
you're healthy and that's like a lot of
people i know in the 18
and above age we've like got the booster
the first booster in december so are you
saying
if you're in that range like you got it
in december or january should people be
thinking about doing it now yeah so we
know uh we
that we have persistent and powerful
immunity uh stretching past six months
in younger and healthier people so it's
not an obligation to get a booster dose
if you're young and healthy
and have no underlying
risk to this virus we know your risk of
hospitalization is low and your level of
protection remains relatively constant
for for that population so the real call
for 18 to 59 years of age is anyone that
wasn't in that 60 and over age group
with underlying illness um but to please
consider coming forward uh as soon as
possible
another
point i want to assure if ontarians get
a dose
this second booster dose
we will have a minimum separation
between the fall dosing and this dose
but it will not interfere with your
eligibility for the fall which is a
combined vaccine which may have two uh
different strains of uh covet 19 in it
what i'm hearing it doesn't sound like
you're saying that if you are a healthy
young adult that you actually really
need a second booster dose so i mean
do you agree that all adults need this
so for the second booster dose my real
call to arms from 18 to 59 is anyone
that
has an underlying illness for the
general healthy individual a healthy 19
year old at this point if they've had
their two dose initial primer and a
first booster we know your level of
protection is going to be very good in
the next several months and we
i would advise that it's not absolutely
necessary at this point
and that you can wait for the fall
booster dose at that point so this dose
is really for those that are vulnerable
to this virus to continue to protect we
absolutely are monitoring
internationally as you're hearing there
will be other strains that we need to
maintain protection for uh and protect
our health system for and hence the
increase in eligibility for today is not
just for this wave but subsequent waves
that will be coming that we're all
anticipating but those people were
already eligible people that were
immuno-compromised and seniors so why
expand eligibility if you're not really
strongly encouraging other people to
also now thank you so if you're 18 to 59
and immune suppressed absolutely you
should have a three dose primary series
your first booster and now a second
booster we'd anticipate that those
individuals were immune suppressed in
ontario
should at this point be eligible for
five full doses for the general
population our call is for those with
any underlying illness whether it's
related to your heart your lung kidneys
liver disease immune issues
those are the individuals we'd love to
come forward to further protect them as
we await
further clarity when the fall bivalent
vaccine will be available
do you anticipate that ontario will have
access to the
omicron targeted vaccine this fall
yeah we absolutely
anticipate that we'll have a bivalent
vaccine in the fall we're getting
clarity though on what uh that omicron
variant will be as you've heard from the
fda they are they're requesting a ba4
five variant the component of that
bivalent we know the manufacturers have
already created a ba1
bivalent vaccine and that may be
available for distribution in uh in
september
so
we're waiting for guidance both from the
who from health canada the public health
agency of canada to ascertain what will
be the components of the fall vaccine
and which ingredient
of the omicron strains will be the core
component so some unclarity
from those discussions yet
if it's going to be a ba-4 ba-5 i
anticipate they'll have to ramp up
production and it would be somewhat
delayed so that might be november or
december hence again the reason that
we're
with that lack of clarity on what's
going to be available to us in ontario
we've opened up the eligibility for 18
to 59 to continue to protect ontarians
with the maximum level of protection
from
this second booster so if you're a
healthy adult no underlying conditions
is it okay to wait for that booster
you can seek independent consideration
from your health care provider but if
you're young uh no underlying medical
illness have had at your first two doses
so your primary series plus your first
booster i think it's it's fine to wait
at present because your risk of
hospitalization and severe outcomes at a
population level is very very low what
do you believe is the actual daily case
count today the actual case count in
your mind
oh i i think our as the pcr testing is
is
not representative of the true actual
count you i think you could do use a
multiplier of three or four times the
actual case count so if uh if we had
1500 today and i'm sorry i don't have
that number right in front of me if we
could anticipate at least 5000 ontarians
carrying the virus
that we're about two weeks today
from the peak is there any consideration
to reinstating other public health
measures like mass mandates at this time
no we're not um considering recommending
recommending to government any further
public health measures i think ontarians
have been prudent have been cautious
when i go indoors or take public transit
many people my age continue to wear a
mask and i think that's brilliant
and as we're seeing the call to arms is
working
we went from around 8 000 on average per
day in ontario to 16 000 people
immunized yesterday and i i
absolutely uh hope uh and uh anticipate
that we'll we'll be seeing those numbers
increase day by day in the coming uh
weeks two years ago if we had case
numbers in the five thousands that would
have sent shock waves through the entire
province certainly uh through kingston
as well
how are you comfortable with that amount
of of covet 19 spreading in the
community today
it's been a remarkable change over time
when we didn't have a vaccine we didn't
have therapeutics
and we didn't have long-acting
protection for the most immune
suppressed like every shelter i think
canada and ontario in particular have
done so well because we've used science
we've been using these therapeutics we
have one of the highest immunization
rates in the world i'd certainly like to
see our first and second booster doses
higher to further protect each other and
our health system
we've prescribed over 25 000 treatments
with paxlovid and i just want to remind
the public that that's a free medication
there's no cost to the individual
and that's one of the highest rates of
prescribing of pak slovak in the country
as well for every sheld we have one of
the highest utilizations of that
medication to protect the most immune
suppressed in our community so
our health partners our primary care
physicians pharmacies have have been
brilliant
at
prescribing at vaccinating and
protecting our communities and it's only
because of that we're at the point where
absolutely 5000 individuals carrying
this virus won't have a significant
impact on our system um due to the high
levels of protection we have in our
communities can i ask about the health
care system in general how
what's your assessment of what's going
on in ontario's hospitals because we're
seeing icu's closing we're seeing uh an
incredible strain and we're seeing uh
healthcare providers leaving the system
what is your assessment of whether or
not the health care system is
paid right now
my heart goes out to all the frontline
workers i know they're doing their very
best i just remind the public that they
have to continue to adhere to all of the
infection prevention and control
measures so they're masking down gloving
gowning every single day changing
between patients it slows their ability
to care for patients quickly
especially in emergency departments they
don't want emerge departments to be a
spread of infection so i ask ontarians
to continue to be kind caring and
considerate with our frontline
healthcare workers they're absolutely
doing their best certainly there are
staffing issues that need to be dealt
with we need
people are
tired fatigued need their time away
and
that will lead to some staffing issues
but i'll remind ontarians i i we monitor
emergency department visits 20 000
ontarians are getting seen every day uh
treated uh and cared for appropriately
four thousand people are getting
admitted to hospital on a daily basis
the system's still working uh at a very
high functional level although
there will be regional issues with
staffing from time to time
whether it's due to covet issues uh and
or
um a rise in cases from injuries
accidents traumas etc
it's 11 18.
he started at 11 o'clock
18 minutes with the chief medical
officer of health this is the first news
conference he's had since what may since
before massachusetts
if why do you let the health minister's
pr person direct the news conference
i hope we'll have a chance for rapid
tests as well after this
oh yeah yeah so
are you making any recommendations to
the government in terms of having to
redeploy healthcare staff to some of
those um
icus that are um struggling right now so
ontario health is doing all of that work
uh so matt anderson and his team with
regional leads um my goal uh is to
prevent any impact of kovid on the
health care system and i'm happy at
present that we've had high prescribing
rates for paxlovit that we've which
should decrease hospitalization the need
to go to an emergency department and or
be in hospital
and if ontarians heed the call and we
continue to have a rise in immunizations
as we as i've stated from 8 000 to 16
000 on a daily basis that alone should
also help protect the health care system
so
these waves appear to be coming on every
90 day basis now if you count between
ba-1 ba-2 ba-5
and it may be these undulating waves
will have an untoward effect on the
health care system and we'll have to be
prepared for those going forward and
certainly we're doing fall preparedness
as well and hope that
excellent vaccine
be able to fall system impact of covid
in the fall as well so that we can
have a strong recovery of our health
care system and all the backlog and any
surgical procedures that are there so
we're working hand in glove daily
meetings to try to respond to any
threats
at a regional level but i do just want
to reiterate
how hard our frontline workers are are
performing
and that
due to all the added protections that
are necessary to protect our health
system against kovid um they are slowed
down somewhat so remain kind and
considerate to our frontline staff
by waiting for first
we waited much longer than quebec did
i'll just keep why
what what did ontario gain by that
so
my biggest issue was just getting the
five million who are still eligible for
the first before we'd expand to the
second and then having a risk based
approach for the second booster dose
as you've heard many ontarians have yet
to heed the call
although it's starting to ramp back up
so we did a risk-based assessment and
risk-based approach to the first and
second booster dose
quebec has opened it up but not many
people under 68 years of age have come
forward for their second booster doses
i hope our targeted approach
is really to those 18 to 59 with any
medical illness any risk of getting
hospitalized please come forward and get
this second booster dose so uh i hope
ontarians will understand we did it in a
risk-based uh evidence-informed approach
with guidance from our ontario
immunization advisory committee
vaccine sorry if you get a fourth dose
like on the 14th
how long would you have to wait to get
divided like three months or what is the
actual story we don't have clarity yet
on those but we anticipate uh like our
previous booster recommendations it can
be as short as three months if
especially if you're immune suppressed
you're just going to be finishing
chemotherapy or cancer treatment of any
type
so it can be as short as three months
normally we would recommend a five month
interval between the booster doses
and that most likely will be the
recommendation for the bivalent vaccine
so if you're getting a second booster in
july you can anticipate august september
october november december november
december would be an appropriate time we
we believe that we'll have gotten
through the high risk groups in october
and november depending on availability
of the vaccine and then be able to open
it up to the general public thereafter
so that that timing will not interfere
or slow down um
if you get your second booster dose uh
in july
are you planning anything specific to
get
we'll work with all the community
partners in those
areas to ensure that vaccines accessible
and available and govax buses are
absolutely part of our strategy as well
as working with vulnerable communities
do you expect your recommendation for
young and healthy individuals to change
one steel micron variant
vaccines come in default yeah we
absolutely will be doing a first a
risk-based rollout of the vaccine to get
it to our long-term care facilities
retirement homes over 60 and then a
population-based approach so they will
remain eligible for a fall
dose no matter what uh booster uh
boosters that they've had by telling
them right now that they don't need it
do you expect them to change their minds
when it comes to fall all right
we'll have further evidence on the
benefit of having a bivalent vaccine so
it may be that having an omicron
component to the vaccine will absolutely
decrease the risk of transmission not
only severe outcomes so they'll be less
prone to getting the virus but also less
prone to transmitting the virus that's
certainly our hope
with a new bi-valent vaccine because if
you remember early on the virus was very
effective at transmission
and severe outcomes and that would be
our hope with a new vaccine
that we
would absolutely see a decrease in risk
of both transmission of the virus at a
population community level and severe
outcomes so that for a younger person
that could be quite helpful are you
ruling out uh completely bringing back
restrictions like mass mandates what
would the threshold be for bringing
something like that back thanks for that
so we're in touch with our healthcare
partners certainly if the capacity of
our health system is threatened to be
able to provide emergent care or
hospitalized care and or icu care we're
certainly not at that point we have
capacity we're roughly 70 of our icu
beds are being utilized and we've made
some projections we're at roughly 119
ontarians are in in the intensive care
unit today that will go up over the next
two weeks but it shouldn't
impede uh or impact any uh uh local
hospitals ability to care for
individuals so if that is threatened um
we we would make recommendations to
government on universal masking in
multiple settings
that's a contingency plan for the fall
it's certainly not
a contingency for the present
before
sorry i just wanted to just get
clarification if i'm a young healthy
person
should i be getting a fourth vaccine
dose right now when omicron is
spreading so quickly and we haven't even
hit
you know the peak at this point we're
weeks away from that or should i just
wait until the fall so if you've had
your first two doses and your first
booster we would not uh you may get a
second booster dose
but it's uh it's not a should it is
absolutely a may depending on your
personal uh circumstances
and again you'd look at whether you have
any underlying medical illness
and or by your occupation are you
getting exposed to anyone
and or
in your
personal life setting if your parent is
undergoing chemotherapy absolutely you
may want to consider getting a a
second booster dose because it does have
an ability to decrease your transmission
risk it wasn't 100 or high 90s like it
was early on it's around 60 percent
decrease in risk of transmission uh and
then
and then at rapidly deteriorates over
months the ability to transmit the virus
so if you have a question and it's not
clear to you uh please consider speaking
to your nurse practitioner your health
care provider uh to to get any further
clarity
is better than nothing so why not just
recommend it to everybody instead of
saying it's a personal decision because
at present we're doing a risk-based
approach
what's the risk
the risk there's always a risk to uh to
having any therapeutic versus a benefit
you want to make sure there's a very
strong benefit uh versus the risk that
if for an 18 year old healthy individual
the risk to getting hospitalized
hospitalized if we have no underlying
medical illness
is very very low we know there is a risk
a very small risk one in five thousand
that may get myocarditis for example uh
and uh you'd have to have that
discussion on the risk benefit of a
complication from the vaccine versus a
benefit of decreased hospitalization for
a young healthy person agree with this
decision then to open it up widely to
all adults
did you agree with this decision yes
with the nuances of the language that
i'm trying to get across of should
should get vaccinated if you've got an
underlying illness may get vaccinated
under personal circumstances uh but with
the caveat as well i don't want anyone
thinking this will block their ability
to get the bivalent in the fall it it
should not
verify that the myocarditis risk my
understanding was that it fell rapidly
for second and third doses is that
something that people should still be
worrying about in third and fourth yes
you're right it can
drop off but for a young healthy male
individual it's still a concern it may
be less than one in five thousand but
we'd have to still do that discussion
with an individual
sorry for my colleague cynthia mulligan
she wants to know if i'm immuno
compromised i've had four shots already
should i get a fifth now and another one
in the fall too yeah so if it's if it's
been three months since that last uh
dose absolutely if you're immune
suppressed so our expectation for anyone
immune suppressed 18 years of age and
over is a three-course primary series
with a first booster and followed by a
second booster and they can be separated
the second booster can be separated by
as much as five months but if you're in
active immune suppression that can be as
short as three months
um
we are
there's some evidence there that perhaps
they're not detecting this latest
variant do you see that that is the case
and what should people be doing so the
rapid tests uh
will continue to be accessible through
all of those venues uh that ontarians
are used to
picking up their
kits
the we do regular analysis in
partnership with public health ontario
on the sensitivity of the test to be
able to detect the virus it has gone
down from strain to strain through va
one two and five but it's still around
the fifty sixty percent sensitivity
marker so if it's positive we consider
it a true positive certainly given where
where we're at in the pandemic if it's
negative one negative test it does not
rule out covet 19. you'd want to do
another 24 hours apart make sure you're
having good technique follow the video
so nose
buckle mucosa and throat
and follow the instructions properly two
negatives uh it is less likely that you
have covet 19 but if you're at risk or
having severe symptoms you still may be
eligible
for a pcr test in that instance okay
thank you folks
thank you thank you steven thank you
thanks